welcome to my talk babesa a meta
circular interpreter for the command
line uh I'm going to explain what that
means in this talk uh my name is mikil
bant I'm from the Netherlands um my name
on the Internet is Bor dude uh I made
that up when I was 20 years and then I
was stuck with it and um okay a little
bit about closure and
me uh I met uh functional programming at
University I was introduced to uh to a
language called Miranda which is a
predecessor to high school and during
towards the end of my studies I was
introduced to common lisp uh which is a
lisp obviously and I like both
approaches and actually closure combines
those two approaches functional
programming and lisp
uh when I was a CS lecturer for a while
I had to teach Java to students and I
took closure as an opportunity to learn
more about the GM most people already
know the GM and then go to closure but I
went the other
direction and um so closure is a lisp on
jvm that emphasizes functional
programming uh oh yeah by the way when I
when I did common lisp I I thought I was
doing fun fun programming but um I I
kind of missed the point of immutability
there which is like the big difference
that closure brings to to this uh I I
tried many other languages I I uh used
hcll I even have hasool running in
production still like a hobby project uh
pure script Scala um but at the end of
the day I just love working with closure
it makes me happy and also I can make a
living from it which is uh a nice thing
you can actually use it for work
something that you love and you can use
it for work it's a perfect combination
for me and I want to use closures uh
standard Library everywhere I just uh
love how how elegant that the standard
library is so uh a question is closure
dead yet uh commonly asked on or
discussed on Hecker news uh ju just a
few thoughts uh in the last two years
I've been making a modest income from uh
doing closure open source work uh
through sponsorship on on GI up sponsors
and other channels um so if closure was
a dead ecosystem it's a miracle that I
can make an income from that uh so there
exists something called closur is
together which is an organization which
supports closure open source um it's
it's they have quite they fun funded
quite some amount of people uh there is
a company called newbank which is the
largest online bank in South America
which has more than 1,200 closure
developers you don't hear a lot about
this in like on Hacker News maybe but it
does exist uh there's many other
companies which which uh have closure at
Central to their technology stack um I'm
not going to name them all but um
uh okay and so and once you know closure
closure is a small language once you
know the standard Library uh well enough
you don't ask that many questions on
stack Overflow for for the reason that
maybe uh the question has already been
asked 10 years ago and it's still valid
today because closure doesn't change uh
that fast and um also that closure has a
very tight Community uh there is cluan
slack where there's like more than I
don't know how many people but thousands
of developers are discussing things over
the over there so before your question
even reaches stack Overflow it's
probably already answered over there and
um and it's a small language that
certainly helps uh and most questions by
the way are not about closure but but
about the whole system that you're that
closure is sitting on top of like the
jvm or or JavaScript or uh things like
that um so closure doesn't make breaking
changes um so code that worked 10 years
ago still works today and that's ideal
for longlived stable projects uh like
the jvm itself it's a very stable
platform um and so there's not much hype
around closure it doesn't change that
that it doesn't make any radical uh
changes so babesa is a sub Community
within the closure community and it even
has its own conference I'll show a
picture at the end of the the
presentation and so so long live dead
languages I would say okay so what is
bashka um so here we see an invocation
on the command line BB minus E + 1 to 3
and then it spits out six uh so this is
a closure expression and it only takes
13 milliseconds to run I mean it depends
on your operating system but uh this is
kind of the range that you can expect
and it's a native closure scripting tool
it's a single binary you don't need an
additional jvm to run this but it does
uh Implement a large subset of the same
jvm closure that you're used to that
many people in the closure ecosystem are
are used to um and you can use this tool
to replace the gray areas of bash uh
when I'm writing a bash script with
nested if else that's already where I
feel that I have to look up
documentation but if if I would do it in
closure it would be very natural for me
so bees is focused uh on closure
developers that need scripting in their
projects and don't want to change
languages it's easily installable via uh
multiple pack package managers so this
is the main problem that it solves on
the top we see closure on the jvm that
uh that just executes an expression it
doesn't really matter what the
expression is here but this is just the
raw startup time that you that you get
with a normal gvm and closure uh it
takes about half a second on this very
laptop uh if you have um a lot of
dependencies like the babesa project
itself has a large number of
dependencies it can already take 7
seconds so the more dependencies you
have the longer it takes but with babesa
it only takes 22 milliseconds and all
these dependencies are already uh
available so how is that possible uh
first we're going to look at an example
script to give you an idea what what
kind of scripts you can create um so
here we're we're compiling some Java of
course we're not using Maven but we're
writing a script to do ourselves I mean
this is just an example um so we're
comparing a class file here to a Java
file and if the Java file is newer then
we're invoking Java C and else we're
just skipping it and we we're not paying
like the startup cost of of java C so
it's a very simple script that you might
do with make or uh but in this case you
can do it with
bashka another example script uh here
here we write a script to show what's
the current time in the Pacific time
standard time um and you don't have to
understand these uh details but the the
main idea is that you can also do Java
interrupt with babesa so it's not
limited to like just calling closure
functions but you can do Java interrupt
like you like you can do in a normal jvm
and this still is instant on your
command line uh of course as closure
developers um yeah so if we have like
this verbose Java interop sometimes we
like to hide it behind the library oh by
the way I should tell this all also
works on windows so not only on Linux
like B scripts tend to be written for
with Linux in mind but all the scripts
that you write with babes also work
automatically on on Windows because it's
built on jvm technology and jvm
Technology is built with crossplatform
in
mind um okay here we see the same script
and now we we're uh adding uh library
from the closure DVM ecosystem uh to our
script it's called tick and then we on
on the last two lines we call the tick
library and do the exact same thing so
this example is showing that you can
reuse libraries that were written for
closure jvm in babesa and we
uh we can reuse this ecosystem so you
don't have to start a new ecosystem we
can tap into the existing one so uh in
babesa there is a large number of
libraries included that that you would
typically need for scripting like uh
command line parsing CSV um XML
yaml um HTTP yeah there is an HTTP
server http client etc etc so things you
would typically need are already
provided for you so you don't need to
pull those in from the
ecosystem um but okay there is a risk of
including these libraries because in the
closure ecosystem we tend to Value um uh
not making any breaking changes like if
you write a library and you upgrade this
Library the user should never have to
change their code uh uh to to keep the
script running and this is a little bit
different than some other uh ecosystems
do like for example in uh I mean yeah so
there is this idea of semantic
versioning that if you uh release
version two of your library it's okay to
make breaking changes but in closure
script we have another way of solving
this is by just renaming your library or
providing different name spaces for for
version two while keep keeping uh
version one in place so users don't uh
uh yeah don't experience these breaking
changes but when including these
libraries in bashka there is a risk that
I am including a library that makes
breaking changes and that in turn uh
could um break existing babesa scripts
so I'm trying to yeah um work together
with the library authors that it it
doesn't happen but General uh in the
closure ecosystem this is a high high
valued uh principle
so um yeah and Al also for me once a
library uh is included in Bas I can also
cannot remove it because this would
break things even if the libraries or
some functions are
deprecated um so imagine Unix command
line tools changing their output every
year like we have LS version 2 now and
it outputs Json and it's awesome but uh
so you cannot really build a platform on
top of that mentality right if so if you
want to know more about that culture you
can watch the speculation talk by Rich
hickey the the author of closure um yeah
it's uh worth checking out okay so there
is a large number of other libraries
that you can use from the closure
ecosystem just as an external dependency
like I showed in in that example where
we use an external dependency um this is
not an extensive list but just to show
that that there is a huge
overlap uh there is a closure test
Runner built into closure itself which
is also part of babesa when is the last
time that you buil uh wrote a test for
bash script Pro for me it's probably
eight years ago but for closure code I
tend to write tests so that's also nice
benefit of of using this language for
scripting so how is this possible that
we have this fast startup um so I'm
using grvm native image which Thomas
showed uh or spoke about in the last
talk uh and the awesome thing that I
find is that you can build command line
tools with instant startup from existing
closure gvm
technology uh two examples that I wrote
prior to babesa is uh one is called
selia condo it's a lintern aesthetic
analyzer for closure uh and it's just
also a single binary and you can throw
some closure code at it and it spits out
some warnings about it so this was prior
to babesa and the other tool is called
jet or one other tool there are many
more but uh and you can convert between
Jon Eden and Transit um and there is a
query language so it's kind of similar
to JQ so here we see s condo in action
uh on the left we have a piece of clo
closure code it's a function Fu which
returns a number and then on the next
line we see first Fu 10 uh and it gives
a type warning because Fu returns a
number and you cannot call First on a
number and that's what we see on the
right on the second line it says
expected seekable collection uh but I
received a number and there are uh some
other warnings there uh so that's what s
the condo does it analyzes your code and
spits out warnings
um and also it can return uh just data
about your code so in addition to to
warnings and this is used by the closure
LSP tool to implement the LSP protocol
for closure so the LSP protocol can be
used to provide navigation and renaming
and stuff like that for your editor
that's also done on top of
salono uh so the other tool is was
called or still is called Jet and it's
it's um a tool to yeah to either
transform or data or query data and uh
initially I wrote a DSL thing for this
to query your data using a closure like
thing closure like language but I didn't
like the fact that it was like closure
and not closure itself So eventually I
started wondering can I
Implement like can I evaluate some just
some closure in instead of this this
DSL uh okay so here we see an example of
the simplest way of of trying that
concept this is like the the simplest
implementation of
bashka we uh we have a main function and
we get the second argument which is this
plus one to3 argument and then we call
load string and enclosure load string is
combination of parsing the closure code
and then evaluating the closure code uh
but if you try to compile this with
graum Native image you get an error
message about uh bite code that has not
been um predefined or basically it
cannot turn the bite code into machine
code at runtime because native image
does this ahead of time uh and you can
maybe now feel the challenge coming up
so how do we replace load string with uh
something else that does work inside
native image so that we can still have
the fast startup but still can
dynamically evaluate some closure code
so uh a famous language researcher
called Thomas weringer said constraints
Force creativity and innovation in the
previous uh presentation actually he
said that uh and that's uh in my case uh
that uh inspiration was uh is called the
small closure interpreter so this is
what basically replaces load string uh
it works inside of a jvm inside of a gra
grvm native image but also in
JavaScript uh and it supports sandboxing
which is a nice bonus feature it's not
strictly necessary for bashka but it's
just a nice nice to have basically uh it
works inside closure script Advanced
compilation uh if you don't know what it
is um it yeah it's a way of of making
the the the output the JavaScript output
of the closure script very small but it
does very aggressive optimizations it a
bunch of renaming going on um and so uh
The Interpreter can be used in
combination with those aggressive
optimizations um and it supports almost
all of closure not all of closure and
this has to do with limitations of those
environments or mostly native image
where I cannot Define new Java classes
like at runtime there is some support
for the for this but it's uh it's this
is like a gray area of this uh approach
uh it's this interpreter is online uh on
GitHub open source uh under the bashka
organization and this is an example so
here we call the The Interpreter with a
function or string that contains a
function and then we get back a function
and we can just call this function in
our host environment uh there is no uh
weird proxy thing going on that you have
to convert between data types it's just
regular closure function that you can
call from from closure um so uh by
default Sai seci only exposes closure
core so if you want to add libraries
like I did in babesa you have to create
a
configuration so you say you have an a
map called
namespaces and then a key chesar doc
core which is a Json library in this
case case and then we expose the
generate string function and then we
pass the Json generate string uh
function from our host environment and
if we provide this configuration to SAI
we can uh execute the same uh
Expressions as in our host environment
but then under the uh the the
constraints of native image let's
say uh so s is a meta circular
interpreter what does that mean so Sai
implements language features of closure
in terms of uh host closure's own
language features so uh and there is
even a more strict definition which is
self interpreter uh where the
interpreted language is the same as the
host language so I'm implementing
closure inclosure but you could for
example also Implement python enclosure
if you wanted it but that this is a self
interpreter
um so for example function imple
Implement uh application can be
implemented using closures apply
function uh that's not the most
performant thing to do but that's a good
start uh and for example Loop inai is
implemented in uh using Loop enclosure
and but pure functions like plus and AO
so pure as in they don't cause side
effects uh can just be direct reference
to the host functions because there is
no point in in reimplementing those we
can just use them and but side effecting
functions often are reimplemented like
creating Nam spaces or defining
functions um uh to make size sandbox
which again is not strictly necessary
for bashka but it's just a nice nice to
have so here is an example of how you
can Implement a metac circular uh
function application
in a couple of lines of closure so in
closure we always start at the bottom of
the code so we start reading in the
comand form command is a way enclosure
to to not evaluate this when the
compiler sees the file but you can
evaluate this from your reppel using
interactive development so we have this
minus eval uh invocation and then we
pass it a map which is which uh let's
call it the
context and we set the current namespace
to User it's just a name and then we
Define some name spaces uh user and then
a function Fu and then the function is a
function of three arguments and which
adds those up and then we evaluate the
expression f 1 to three so so we
evaluate this thing and we get back six
so what happens
is if we pass this uh expression to to
the minus eval function we check if it's
a list-like thing which is done using
the seek question mark function en
closure and if that's the case then we
go to apply minus apply and in minus
apply you see that I reused uh closure's
own apply function to apply the function
that I look up using minus resolve in
the context and then also evaluate the
arguments so this is very simple uh not
most performant uh way of doing it uh
but okay to get things working and to
see if things actually work in in grow
VM and to see if like version 001 it's
good
enough uh lead bindings similar approach
but lead bindings cannot reuse closures
uh L directly because uh lad enclosure
is a very static
feature um you cannot say Okay um yeah
it's it's just too static to to reuse in
the interpreters you you don't know
beforehand what kind of lead bindings
the user is going to provide so instead
of doing uh reusing closures that we're
going to use an immutable hash map which
is just a map of symbols to values and
we just store the locals the L bindings
in there so we start at the bottom again
we call minus eval with an empty map and
then a let expression that x uh be 10
and then we return X okay so we go to
the minus eval
function then we check if it's a seek
and if the first symbol is a let if
that's the case we go to minus let we
pull out uh the local symbol and the
value and we evaluate the the
value and then we store that value in
the locals map which is part of the the
context and then we evaluate the body of
the lead uh using that context in scope
um and if it's actually if the the
expression is a symbol which is the body
of the lead here then we call minus
local and that just gets the local out
of this map that we
constructed using the right value so
this is again very simple approach uh in
one
slide uh more yeah a little bit more
challenging is uh Lambda so function
creation uh again we have um on the
bottom we have a minus eval invocation
uh we pass an empty map which is the
context and then uh a function
expression which has three arguments and
we just return the last one and then we
uh call F1 to 3 on the function that we
got back and that should return three so
uh again we use uh in the context we use
a locals uh immutable hash map for this
and you can see that the minus fun
function reuses actually closure's own
fun uh
construct uh okay so this is the the
first the naive approach let's say so we
parse an expression and then we throw
the expression at the The
Interpreter um so let's say we're
evaluating Plus One
X and so that gets us back a list of a
symbol plus a number one and the symbol
symbol X so if we're going to evaluate
this uh you can see in
green um that we're doing a lot of work
just to evaluate this expression but
suppose that we're doing this inside of
a loop so uh let's say we're we're
evaluating this expression
4X uh range and then a large number and
then we're uh evaluating Plus One X uh
every time we're evaluating Plus One X
we're looking up that the symbol plus
refers to a
function in uh enclosure core and that
one is a constant and that X is a local
and so only actually everything that is
in green we could do only once and not
every time we visit this expression uh
and the things in purple we yeah that's
the only thing you actually need to do
at um uh runtime so there's lots of
optimization uh to be gained
there uh actually this approach is also
described in the book structure and
interpretation of computer programs uh
chapter 4 if you want to know more about
this
approach and so basically Sai splits up
uh things ins into an analyzer phase
which we see on the top left and an
evaluator that that then evaluates what
the analyzer returns so the idea is do
as much as possible uh on the left and
then do as little as possible on the
right when you actually evaluate these
nodes
repeatedly so instead of doing this uh
walking of of uh expressions and then
directly evaluating them we turn this
plus1 2x expression into a data
structure that knows how to evaluate
itself very
quickly and then um yeah so that's where
a lot of performance uh comes from okay
so initially that was not a goal first I
wanted to know does this approach
actually work and then later on I
started to optimize stuff uh so for
example here we have a loop of 10
million
iterations uh with three conditionals no
sorry one conditional and three function
calls so we're just go we have two count
counters and we check if one counter is
positive if so we uh do a recursion with
the incremented value of the one and a
decremented value of the the second one
and so in uh in seci in Native image
this uh this runs in a little bit more
than half a second compared to jvm
closure this is very slow uh but there
is just uh more overhead in the The
Interpreter but let's um compare it to
python for example which is also an
interpreter then it's uh actually faster
so this is the same example but
converted to Python and ran on the same
machine and uh this is almost 900
milliseconds while in SE it is uh a
little bit under 600
milliseconds so if you're wondering does
bashka is is based on this interpreter
is it fast enough for scripting compared
to jvm closure well if python is fast
fast enough for you then babesa is
probably also fast enough for for
scripting
purposes um so initially the very naive
approach is on the left I started
measuring um old versions of babesa that
that ran this Loop example first it took
16 seconds and this is measured in Linux
on a different Machine by the way but
lower is is better so it's all relative
and uh right now this example runs below
a second on um x64 hardware and so what
one thing that really helped was
splitting up analysis and evaluation but
there is another thing that that uh
really helped was not using immutable
hashmaps for these locals so for example
here we have a
function which is actually a closure so
it closes over the values A and B and um
it has one argument and in the body of
the function is a lat expression which
also has one binding so those are four
things you you should store in this
hashmap so it's a dynamically stored
hashmap that now has four things but we
can already statically see that it only
needs four things so if we manage to
replace this immutable hash map by uh an
array with only four positions it's
actually
um 15 times faster and um so the the the
immutable hashmap approach is very
elegant and you don't need to think
about threat safety it's all immutable
and but so once you go to the fixed
array stuff which requires more
analysis um and also you have to start
thinking about threat safety you you
have to make a tradeoff like is this
worth the extra complexity and I thought
eventually that it's worth the extra EXT
ra
complexity um so you need to
pre-allocate uh these arrays and then
calculate these indexes where to read
each local
from um so basically asso bindings A1
becomes a set bindings uh 01 if you
decide that a is going to be in the the
zeroth position of this array and and
similarly getting The Binding becomes a
get using an index so this this makes uh
yeah 15
times uh at least the local part of The
Interpreter 15 times faster uh but it
does yield extra complexity so this is a
real piece of code from SII it's a macro
which generates 42
functions and each function is specific
for one aity of of a function that is
going to produce
and you see a bunch of uh copying of
values from one array to another array
and um yeah so it's it's a lot more
complex and so at this point Sai has
lost its educational value because you
you could follow the examples at the
beginning of of this presentation but
this is harder to understand certainly
when you're first reading it so yeah
that's a shame but um
okay
um so a little bit about interrup how is
that implemented in s um so you have to
provide a
configuration uh all the classes that
you're going to support for your uh
scripting environment so here we support
Java long thread we just passed the
thread class and we also Define imports
which which are the class names that are
uh available by default
enclosure you but it's configurable in
this environment enironment and then uh
to make this work with gra VM native
image you also need to provide a
reflection
configuration uh such that all the
metadata of the classes are still
available at runtime and then Sai uses
reflection to look up the right methods
uh that are going to be invoked and this
invocation is done through reflection um
uh at at runtime so when you evaluate
threat sleep 100 what happens is at an
analysis time we can already see okay
this is the class threat but the Sleep
Method actually depends on the type of
of the argument so we cannot know this
ahead of time unless unless we uh re use
the fact that it's 100 that it's past
year but it it's not always uh clear uh
but there is room for performance
enhancements still in this area by Yeah
by resolving more of this type
information at analysis time but
currently it's just reflection
based uh so another uh concern in bashka
is the binary size of course uh I would
like to BB is a single binary BB is
stands for bashka by the way I didn't
explain that yet but that's what the the
binary is is called and of course I want
BB to be as small as possible right now
of for the last 2 years it's been around
80 megabytes and it's been fairly stable
uh it kind of depends on on what grm
version I'm I'm using but things are
tend to become smaller with each release
now but this hasn't been always the case
but and um but so that that that brings
in a little bit variation and of course
the majority of the size is what
libraries do I include so more Li
built-in libraries and more built-in
classes means bigger binary size so
that's also a trade-off to make um
so it's not always uh clear beforehand
which libraries are nice to have and
sometimes user asks like can we have
this Library built into babesa uh but
it's not always clear how many users
will actually use that Library so this
is why there's one of the reasons that
babesa has an extension mechanism called
pods which uh are external binaries that
can expose functions to bashka Via an
RPC mechanism
and it means compiling more grow VM
binaries uh but they these binaries can
also be built using goang or hll or
whatever language as long as the binary
Returns the right
data and Below we see an example of
using the instaar library from a pod uh
and this works well if functions return
data uh that can be serialized back and
forth uh if that's not the case then
this approach uh breaks a little bit
there are tricks to work around that by
keeping State inside of this other
binary but uh but enclosure a lot of the
times closure uh functions do uh
communicate via data so that's that's
why this approach uh often works well
okay so s is not only used for Native
image it also works on JavaScript
there's a couple of projects uh that
also use The Interpreter on JavaScript
one is called nbb which is a sister
project of babesa but it stands for node
bashka so you can do scripting on
node.js using closure uh it again it has
a couple of useful built-in
libraries um you can make playgrounds
with your favorite libraries included
for the browser and there's also a
project called Joyride which uh allows
scripting vs code using closure uh so
you don't have to create an extension
for every little thing that you want to
do in vs Cod anymore but you can just
write a little bit of closure to to yeah
to make Joy uh to make vs code as
awesome as
emac
okay
um okay one thing uh to make full circle
uh so s is also used in selia condo
which is a static analyzer for closure
but some people write complicated macros
enclosure that syia condo doesn't always
understand and uh so here we see an
example of uh the usage of s such a
macro which is flow and uh so if you
don't do any configuration you see
unresolved symbol
original and which is actually a local
introduced by this macro uh but if you
write a hook which is interpreted using
Sai you can instruct the static analyzer
to to understand this macro and then you
get actually get very nice uh LSP
support as well because if you stand on
the
double
uh symbol there you see the where it's
defined is lighting up so everything is
clear to the editor now again and this
all works under grm because it's uh
running in
Sai so Sai is built on closure and jvm
uh grow VM technology which means we get
a lot of things for free it's getting
better all the time uh so this is a
complicated example of spawning uh
100,000 threats to add up some numbers
and uh and each um each thread is
sleeping for one second and uh so this
takes 1.6 seconds in total which is
similar if you would run this on the jvm
but you can do this in bashka which is
quite nice for something that replaces
bash
scripts uh so we had our first bashka
conference last
summer um which was very nice uh there
is a babesa workshop as well that you
can uh follow online or uh at various
conferences the last one was at Java
Zone in
Norway uh there is a book online where
you can learn bashka specific things if
you already know a little bit of closure
it's called babuka by Daniel he's also
on this
conference and thanks everyone for
sponsoring my open source projects and
uh my opinion closure is the best
language for scripting that's
[Applause]
it